because i told the story about our  matching tattoo what does it say well  now it says that's right it's wrong too  i'm afraid of everybody  it says i'm afraid of everybody  2003 google translate  google translate  this none of this is making he's korean  i'm chinese right let's pick neutral  territory japanese so we both don't know  the language  you should have picked ireland so then  you could have just wrote in english i  don't fear anyone  it's supposed to be fear no one but  google translate of course [ __ ] it up  so it's like i uh everyone i fear or  something  so the way he found out was my mom was  reading it she goes who's he afraid of  we got it in north carolina the guy's  like hey i don't know the language so  i'm just gonna trust you guys well no we  got it at least he was honest